one last point before we take our first
break here's urban meyer
the coaching staff was announced today
for the jacksonville jaguars
an interesting hire for director of
sports performance a guy named chris
doyle who's got a history that
maybe would make him not an ideal
candidate to have that job
here's meyer on talking about the
decision to bring in chris doyle
yeah i've known chris for uh close to 20
years our relationship goes back to when
i was at utah and he was the
number one strength coach and really he
was doing sports performance before
sports performance became uh
uh a high priority in in college
sports and so i've known him i've
studied him
uh we've had a relationship i vetted him
thoroughly
he had no reservations hiring him based
on the allegations and and what happened
at iowa
and why hire him instead of going in a
different direction
oh sure i i i vet everyone on our staff
and like i said the relationship goes
back
close to 20 years and a lot of hard
questions asked a lot of vetting
involved and
with the with all our staff but uh we we
we did a very good job vetting that one
so you're confident there's not going to
be any issues yeah they're all
very confident did you have to get
shad's permission
to hire him chris doyle uh shad was
involved with our high-end
hires and uh he was very he was involved
and are you at all concerned that him
being in the building will
impact your ability to attract free
agents
uh i if i was i wouldn't have hired him
uh once again i'll explain that if if
that becomes a
question uh the one thing i'm very
confident is that
i would imagine within a year or two of
the best sports performance team in the
national football league
doyle exited the university of iowa
football program
last year amid allegations of some
racially charged comments and just
the kind of old school football player
abuse that coaches engage in when they
yell and scream and they rant and rave
and the game has evolved past that in
many respects and shireen i understand
that you know nfl head coaches are
looking for people they can trust that's
one of the reasons why they hire their
kids because if you can't trust
your kids who the hell can you trust
there's many reasons
beyond that why they look to hire their
own children but it's about who you can
trust
who is with you who will be your eyes
and ears
within the ranks of the coaches and
doyle will be
undoubtedly extremely grateful to and
loyal to urban meyer doesn't make it
right
and it doesn't set the
the right framework i think this is
where it's delicate because myers had a
history of some questionable characters
around him
and here he is bringing in a guy that's
that's got a recently questionable
background when there are plenty of
other people who could do the job that
chris doyle's been hired to do
yeah by all accounts mike he's very good
at his job which is why they hardened
but there's a reason that he had a 1.1
million separation agreement with iowa
after 20 years there
and you know the jaguars should have
known what they were getting
when they hired urban meyer because
he had zach smith on his on his staff
for a long time and we know how that
played out with of course knew what they
were getting when they hired overnight
meyer and this is part of who urban
meyer is and what he does so
this this is what they bought into and
they're going to let him run the show
it's obvious he's in charge mike in
jacksonville
there was an external review of the iowa
program which concluded that a small
group of coaches demeaned players
and the program's rules perpetuated
racial or cultural biases and diminish
the value of cultural diversity
doyle defended himself by saying i do
not make racist comments and i don't
tolerate people
that do but still as you mentioned there
was that buyout the relationship
ended in the aftermath of this
investigation and
urban meyer has plenty of equity as he
enters the nfl especially in
jacksonville
he may have used up a little bit of it
today and there definitely will be
plenty of eyes and ears on chris doyle
and and here's the reality you got a
certain amount of power and control over
college football players that you don't
have over pro players
and if he approaches the line with an
nfl player
he's going to get a far different
reaction than he ever would have gotten
at iowa
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports